first of all most of my all my reviews
are on the internet so the mature i'd
say probably the majority of people that
read my writing are reading it online as
far as the actual reviewing of a
restaurant it's beginning to change it I
think but it you know it's it's changed
more the restaurant reporting and so
there's much more of a sort of a
frenzied people pay pay attention to
what you're doing more at least they
seem to but as far as the actual rhythm
of writing review I mean generally you
want to go to a restaurant a month after
it's opened I generally start going
three weeks to a month average slope
after its open and I generally write it
up within six weeks of its opening now
in internet terms that's a seven decades
you know that's a that's an enormous
length of time but that's still how how
I do it and that's how they do it in New
York magazine and so that hasn't changed
i have a feeling ultimately it will
because the time cycle just keeps
getting collapsed closer and closer and
closer and closer and closer recently i
wrote a review of David Chang David
Chang is the hot chef downtown in the
East Village he runs this the momofuku
Empire and I wrote a review of his
restaurant momofuku co which is a small
omakase a place very elite very hard to
get into it's modeled on on the what I
was talking about Moss's restaurant
uptown it's modeled on that Japanese
model of you know everyone gets the same
meal there are 12 people in the room and
I wrote that I got in i think was the
fifth week who was open and I haven't
this arcane computerized system for
getting in and I had a bunch of people
the magazine log on other computers and
there was a cancellation and I got in
and because i didn't think i was gonna
get in again with anna you know
why didn't know if I get it again and
because they he only serves this one
meal which doesn't very very much i
wrote it up after one visit and and put
it out in the on the internet before it
was published that's the that's the
first time that i've done that maybe
it'll happen again we'll do it more i
don't know